un plan d'action pour la reprise totale
des activités de soins autour du cancer
confinement ils postent confinement
provoqué retards de diagnostic baisse
des dépistages et difficultés
d'accessibilité aux soins
une période où se sont développées des
pratiques alternatives qui inquiète les
professionnels
il faut pas laisser de la place à la
désinformation essaie d information a
beaucoup beaucoup nui au fonctionnement
très bien vu tout ce qu'on a pu
découvrir sur les réseaux sociaux
et puis il ya eu quelque chose qui nous
a beaucoup alimenté à savoir roi
démarrage des dérives sectaires une
recrudescence de la naturopathie
parce que bien donc vous avez des
personnes qui ont à la fois peur et de
leur cancer et d'éventuellement d'avoir
du coup vite donc on y à des
improvisations des retour à des
pratiques je veux dire traditionnel tout
cas non conventionnelles qui ont
conforté pour dans cet épisode les
personnes qu'il faut aujourd'hui ramené
un peu conventionnel dans tout cela
les autorités estiment le retard de
diagnostic a cumulé ces cinq derniers
mois entre 30 et 40 patients le souhait
et ensemble avec les acteurs de pouvoir
agir sur la prévention puisque sur
certains facteurs de risque
ils se sont majorées pendant cette crise
qu vide sur le dépistage le dépistage
des cancers et pendant toutes les phases
du traitement de façon à ce qu elles
s'enchaînent dans de bonnes conditions
et que surtout que les gens ne renonce
pas au traitement du cancer ne renoncent
pas à leur prise en charge
c'est quand cette mesure ont ainsi été
définies pour pallier la perte de chance
de survie ou de guérison mais elle
s'appuie en partie sur un système de
soins déjà saturé
on a un système de santé sous tension
c'est aujourd'hui c'est pas évident
d'avoir des rendez vous notamment pour
l'accès à l'imagerie notamment l'irm des
examens donc on a déjà selon le risque
effectivement ce serait qu'il y ait un
goulot d'étranglement adapté au départ
de consultation dépend plus des tables à
bord et là on s'arrêtait à 17 ans
arrêtera à 19h tactique
aujourd'hui on n'a pas le choix et je
crois que c'est un message de tous les
acteurs doivent entendre et c'est bien
pour cela qu'on prend le temps
d'annoncer nous les orientations
officiellement c'est à dire qu'il faut
que chacun joue le jeu est responsable
et que personne ne soit hypothéquer
parce qu'en fait il ya eu encore vide
c'est à dire qu'on est dans une
situation d'exception aimé y aura des
mesures d'exception
chaque année 1500 nouveaux cas de cancer
sont diagnostiqués en martinique
18000 personnes sont suivies pour cette
maladie